plusieurs livres parlant de la drogue
sans sortie récemment deux ouvrages du
docteur olievenstein tout d'abord que
vous avez entendu dans le reportage
précédent le premier de ces livres
s'intitule la drogue ou la vie il est
paru chez laffont le second livre du
docteur olievenstein est publié chez
fayard son titre vous allez le voir
destin de toxicomanes à ces deux livres
d'un spécialiste il faut rajouter un
roman signé thierry ardisson il s'agit
de rive droite sortie chez albin michel
thierry ardisson a écrit une histoire
sur le thème des années 70 face à la
drogue en france aux usa et en extrême
orient
michel gall a rencontré pour nous
l'auteur de rive droite
on peut penser que c'est un paradis à un
moment mais effectivement c'est encore
pas la solution je crois que la solution
c'est de ces d'assumer ce qui nous
arrivait de ne pas croire qu'il ya d'une
solution sur cette terre alors qu'est ce
qui permet d'en sortir quand on peut en
sortir et votre héros luis va l'ange est
allé très loin un
mais j'imagine qu'il n'est pas quand
même complètement représentatif non
parce qu'il est allé beaucoup plus loin
que la plupart des gens qui ont touché à
sa très peu de gens s'en sortent
moi je me souviens à l'époque où j'en ai
pris un petit peu beaucoup moins que mon
personnage ou en forme et es8 et sur
huit y en a quatre qui sont morts trois
qui sont encore et moi qui ai arrêté
je crois que c'est une position très
dure parce que l'héroïne c'est un style
de vie beaucoup plus qu'une drogue c'est
à dire qu'on ne fréquente plus que des
gens qui ont près non vie complètement
là dedans donc
c'est très difficile d'en sortir ça
suppose de remettre en cause toute sa
vie entre le mysticisme un peu naïf de
son enfance et puis le mysticisme murs
de sa trentaine on peut se demander à
quoi a servi ce grand détour je crois
quand même que ces expériences
asiatiques
l'ont aidé à pas devenir complètement
matérialiste pendant les années 70 ça
c'est déjà pas mal
et effectivement ensuite ils passent de
l'exotisme à l'ascétisme c'est à dire
qu'il se
il en vient à une religiosité beaucoup
plus dépouillée beaucoup plus en plus
efficace plus direct thierry ardisson
qu'est ce qu'on peut dire un jeune qui
est tenté aujourd'hui par cette
expérience ou qui commença à suivre ce
chemin là on peut lui dire déjà que tout
le monde est accroché à quelque chose on
est tous junkie de quelque chose soit de
la télévision soit d'une femme
en tous les cas de l'air qu'on respire
donc ce qu'on peut dire c'est que dans
la vie il faut s'accrocher au moins de
choses possibles et c'est le seul moyen
de garder sa liberté il ya des choses
comme le café du matin auquel on a du
mal à s'accrocher mais je crois qu'on
peut dire qu'il faut s'accrocher au
moins de choses possibles et qu'on peut
très bien s'accrocher à l'herbe même si
c'est pas physique même si c'est
psychologique que c'est vrai que quand
on a fumé un joint c'est plus facile de
prendre de la cocaïne ou de l'héroïne
dont que nos parents avaient raison en
quelque sort et de lui dire surtout ne
jamais prendre d'opiacés c'est à dire
des robinet et d'opium
parce que c'est un gouffre absolue parce
que l'on s'en sort pas et pour être sûr
de ne rien rater de dinars 10 tubes
abonnez vous il m'était impossible ou